all right thanks for coming so i'll be
talking about extended formulations and
information complexity so i meant this
as sort of
a general introduction to both extended
formulations and how to use tools from
information theory to prove lower bounds
against linear programs
so let me start off with introducing
extended formulations by an example
because i think an example really helps
crystallize why this definition is the
way it is and why it's interesting in
some cases so let me start off with a
nice example called the permetahedron
which is a polytope in n dimensions
which all you do is you take a vector a
fixed vector t
which has integer entries so 1 2 3 all
the way up to n so a length n vector and
you take all possible permutations of
this one fixed vector and you take their
convex hole
so this gives me a very simple polytope
in n dimensions
but when measured by something like how
many facets it has it's actually very
complex
because it has exponentially many facets
so this is not hard to see
in fact it follows just because
you know if you think about a subset s
of indices
and i add up the entries of my vector
just restricted to that set then i add
up these x sub i's for i and s well how
small can this possibly be for any point
in the permeahedron the smallest it
could ever be if was is if those values
are one two all the way up the size of s
so in this way you know this right hand
side i get uh s plus one choose two and
i get a valid inequality on the
prometahedron and it's not too hard to
see that it really is a facet of the
permetahedron
but you can actually do much much better
just using the connection between
permutations and permutation matrices so
even for the simple example i can
drastically reduce the representational
complexity in terms of how many linear
inequalities i need
if i instead think about generating p as
the projection of a higher dimensional
polytope
so if i instead i take q to be a
polytope in n squared dimensions where
it's the set of doubly stochastic
matrices so matrices which are entry
wise non-negative and whose rows and
columns all sum to exactly one
then it turns out not hard to see that
if i take any such a
and multiply it by the vector t then
what i'm going to get out is necessarily
a point that is in the per-metahedron
and that the converse is true too that
actually you know you can actually
represent every point in the perimeter
exactly this way so this is a simple
example which i haven't filled in all
the details to prove that it actually
does work but it's a case where you can
go from exponentially many facets down
to just n squared facets you know
quadratic number
because all i need to do is to define
the constraints that you know q is a set
of doubly stochastic matrices
so this is the idea of an extended
formulation more generally so you can
look at this picture but more generally
the extension complexity of a polytope
is what you do is you have some polytope
and you'd like to represent it as the
shadow of a higher dimensional polytope
so you'd like to say how many
inequalities do you need on a higher
dimensional poly type q what's the best
you can get away with so that you can
express the original polytube you care
about as the projection of q and we've
already seen one example so if we take
the perimeter hedron then that's a
polytube with exponentially many facets
and i showed you that you can get away
with n squared for its extension
complexity turns out you can actually do
n log n and believe it or not that
connection is through the aks sorting
network so that's a fun little result of
gomen's
there's just to give you some more
intuition if you take like a regular
n-gone in the plane so in two dimensions
then actually it's known that its
extension complexity is log n
but there's a very subtle notion because
if i take that same n-gon and i perturb
its vertices ever so slightly
its extension complexity goes up from
logarithmic to root n
and the way that i want to think about
this because i'll really be interested
in using tools from information three to
prove lower bounds against extended
formulations
the way that i want to think about this
in general is through quantifiers
because you can always rotate p and q so
that you really obtain p from a very
simple type of projection where you're
just cutting away some parts of the
vectors so you can think about an
extended formulation in general as
instead you're giving p a different name
where you think about it as all the x's
for which there exists a y so that the
concatenated vector x comma y lives in
this higher dimensional poly tip q that
hopefully has few constraints
so in this way you can actually think
about a nice analogy with quantifiers
and boolean formula so the same way that
you know quantifiers allowing their
exists can help you drastically reduce
the size of functions that you want to
express with simple gates
you know the same way
we really can drastically reduce the
size of
of the number of facets we need
by um by allowing quantifiers by
allowing extended formulations and we
really hope is that we can prove lower
bounds against explicit hard polytopes
so the same way you know one of the
polytopes which has
you know really been of interest in this
area
is the tsp polytube so the same way that
they're polytubes like the permeahedron
which you know things like the
connection between permutations and
permutation matrices give you new names
for those old polytopes
so too you think that they're polytopes
which are just intrinsically hard to
describe more compactly
so one such natural candidate is the tsp
polytobe what you can do is you can take
the complete graph k n
and now you can look at any set of edges
that forms a complete you know
hamiltonian tour and you can look at one
f so the indicator function of that set
of edges
so in this way this is a polytope in n
choose two dimensional space
where you take the convex hull of all of
these indicator functions of sets of
edges that really are hamiltonian
circuits
but the issue is that this polytope is
very difficult certainly you know if you
could optimize over it linear functions
then you really could find the minimum
cost tour so you'd have p equal to np
and really the goal in extended
formulations is to try and prove
unconditional representational lower
bounds that polytopes like this one are
just intrinsically hard and they need
tons and tons of inequalities to
actually perfectly express them
so the other thing i want to mention is
that sometimes there's this confusion in
this literature
about you know how this is related to
proving you know to proving things like
p naught equal then p well in general
when you prove an unconditional lower
bound on representing this polytube
you've said nothing about p not equal
then p
in fact the other is also not true that
these aren't even you know things that
would follow from p not equal to np but
you know the main part in the first part
of this talk what i want to describe is
i want to describe a general program
yannick is set forth in 1990 a very
interesting program for trying to prove
lower balance against this geometric
parameter
against you know is there a
representation for explicit hard
polytopes like this
and the way that he did it was through a
really amazing connection between
geometry and algebra
so this parameter extension complexity
will turn out to be related to something
called the non-negative rank and
ultimately in the stock what i want to
do is i want to show you how you can use
tools from information theory actually
to prove lower bounds against
non-negative rank and against
representational questions like this one
so there's been a ton of work in this
area so i'm going to give you a very
abridged history
so yanukakis in 1990 and i guess what i
like to call the world's best review so
there was a paper which had claimed p
equals np by giving a you know andy the
eighth size lp for tsp
and uh he showed that no the paper was
wrong you know it's one thing to just
say it probably doesn't work but he
actually showed that well it was wrong
for sort of fundamental reason that he
was giving a symmetric extended
formulation
and it's just impossible to give a
symmetric extended formulation for the
traveling salesman polytube which has
sub-exponential size
now the issue is that you know there's a
lot of work in the interim which showed
us things like asymmetric extended
formulations really can be much more
powerful than symmetric ones
and finally in a really amazing result
the fiorini at all what they did was
they showed an exponential lower bound
for the tsp problem the original poly
tip that i described on the previous
slide
in fact it was based on an even stronger
two to the end lower bound for a poly
type that's related to the clique
problem
and moreover it was you know it's almost
amazing that it was just
non-deterministic communication
complexity that was used to prove this
lower bound
so the same way you can see a sort of
progression of techniques and extended
formulations that go through a very
similar progression of techniques that
have been used in communication
complexity
so in fact after that brought bronidal
showed lower bounds even on approximate
extended formulations things that
roughly try and get this polytope
associated with clique right within a
root n factor they showed an exponential
lower bound and their approach was
through raspberrov's rectangle
corruption lemma
and we'll be talking about a little bit
today is about using tools from
information theory to prove stronger
lower bounds that actually any polytope
that gets this um
that even gets within an n to the one
minus epsilon factor right is actually
itself going to have exponential size so
in a sense you know we already had
things like hastad's uh you know lower
bounds that clique is hard to get right
within a factor of n to the one minus
epsilon and these are the unconditional
uh analogs of this and also later in
this workshop uh sebastian pakuda will
be talking about
also about the connection between
information theory and geometry and some
really nice work about using common
information which is a different
information theoretic tool to prove
lower balance against an average case
sense against extended formulations
uh just to sort of tell you a little bit
more about the story chanadel ended up
proving lower bounds against maxcut
based on reductions the shirley adams
hierarchy
thomas proved a lower bound against
perfect matchings approved a two to the
omega and lower bound for extended
formulations for perfect matchings
and in a very recent work uh liadol you
know finally answered what are what's
one of the big open questions or was one
of the big open questions area about
proving lower bounds not just against
linear programs but against
semi-definite versions of extended
formulations
in any case let me you know now cut to
the chase so let me tell you about
yannick as a program and tell you where
information theory fits in so the first
way that i'm going to do this is i'm
going to describe his general connection
between geometry and algebra and the
second part i'm just going to tell you
about an abstract information theoretic
framework i think it helps to see this
framework twice so then we're going to
apply it actually to
the correlation polytope which is one of
the polytopes that comes up over and
over again in this literature
so yannick says factorization theorem is
really you should think about it as
addressing this question how are we
going to prove lower bounds against
extended formulations extended
formulations can be you know quite
strange and difficult to reason about
and at the core of it you know i'll make
this more precise in a second he proved
that this geometric parameter that we
care about the extension complexity of a
polytope
turns out to be exactly related to an
algebraic parameter of some object i'm
about to define right now called the
slack matrix so it's just a complete
reformulation an equivalent
reformulation of what this geometric
parameter i defined was
and the idea is you define a slack
matrix which encodes the rough geometry
of the polytope that's what you want to
preserve through an extended formulation
so let me show you by example we'll take
some polytope in two dimensions to keep
it simple
my drawing abilities are limited so we
take our polytope in two dimensions
and what we want to do is we want to
define a very large matrix which encodes
the geometry
so every row is going to represent a
different facet
of the polytope and every column
represents a different vertex so in this
way for example vj might map to this
column
and this facet may map to this row so
i've defined this extremely large object
the slack matrix at least in terms of
what its rows are and what its columns
are
and all that i have to do to fully
define this is i have to tell you how to
put in the entry
in the corresponding facet and vertex so
which in this row in this column
and all it's going to be
is informally it's the slack it's how
slack this vertex is on this given facet
or to think about it geometrically all
you do is you take the perpendicular
distance so if i take b i minus a i
inner product with v j
then this quantity is how much slack i
have on this given constraint it's a
non-negative value and i put that in the
corresponding row and column
so this is the slack matrix it's a very
very large
entry-wise non-negative matrix which
encodes the geometry namely how the
different vertices and facets interact
and how loose they are on each other
and the basic idea is that an algebraic
parameter on this object is going to
exactly capture the extension complexity
and this is the notion of non-negative
rank so this is what i'll really be
interested in proving lower bounds
against so non-negative rank also has
lots of applications with machine
learning and so on but the basic idea is
we start with our entry wise
non-negative matrix s
and the goal is to write s as the sum of
rank 1 non-negative matrices and use as
few of them as possible
so you know the way to think about this
so precisely what it is it's the
smallest r so that i can write s as the
sum of r rank one non-negative matrices
and you know the key point is this
should look very familiar with the usual
notion of rank because if i drop this
non-negativity restriction and say given
a matrix what's the smallest r so i can
write it as the sum of r rank 1 matrices
that's precisely the rank
non-negativity is this extra constraint
on each of these factors in here which
is where the information 3 is going to
come in
but the key point is what we're really
hoping for is that the non-negative rank
can be
much much larger than the rank of a
matrix that's the same phenomenon that
some polytope and like n or n squared
dimensions can nevertheless turn out to
have exponential extension complexities
exactly a gap between these two
parameters
so yanukox's factorization theorem is
really just this equality
the extension complexity of a polytope a
purely geometric property of what's the
most concise name you can give for a
polytope in terms of how many
inequalities you need to define it
that turns out to be exactly equal to
the non-negative rank of the slack
matrix it's a kind of amazing theorem
it's proof is very short which i will
not give you
but the intuition for this is that it
turns out the right factorization is
exactly the right change of variables to
reduce the number of inequalities you
need
and what i really want to talk about is
how to use this program to actually
prove lower bounds on extended
formulations by using information theory
to prove lower bounds on the right hand
side so are there any questions
yeah how do you handle approximations
here approximately i'll get into that
later that'll also that'll be something
which behaves very smoothly when you
talk about information theoretic tools
but let me hold off on that for the time
being
uh
to prevent things from being too
complicated so let me tell you about a
general framework this framework's not
going to make much sense until i
actually put it into action so if this
looks strange that's fine
so let me tell you about how to use
information theory here the rough idea
is we want to take a too good to be true
non-negative matrix factorization and
use it to sample from a distribution
using too few bits of entropy that's the
plan
so one way that we can realize this plan
is imagine we take our entry-wise
non-negative matrix on the left-hand
side i'm going to use black and colored
squares to note non-zeros and white
squares to note zeros what if i give you
some magical set t of entries which all
have the same value in the left hand
side
so i can think about a very natural
distribution where i choose one of these
green squares uniformly at random
now that has some given entropy but i
can also think about using the right
hand side to sample from that and that's
exactly what i'm going to do
imagine i look at where t occurs in all
of these rank 1 non-negative matrices
and one thing i can do is i can choose
one of these rank 1 matrices
proportional to its total value
on the blue squares how much weight it
assigns to the set t
and then once i've chosen one of those
rank 1 matrices i can choose one of the
blue squares proportional to its
relative value in the matrix
so in this way if i output this square
i'm going to output that corresponding
square
and it's not hard to see that because
i've chosen t to be a set of entries
with exactly the same value
that this procedure generates a random
sample from t
but the key point is that
you know actually based we can use the
structure of the right hand side the
fact that it's rank one to show that if
we have too few of these factors we've
used too few bits of entropy so that's
the general plan
now this plan doesn't make sense until i
realize it so let's use it
and the main point is just if r little r
the number of rank one terms too small
this procedure uses too little entropy
so let me apply it to the correlation
polytope and we'll actually get
disjointness as the problem that we want
to prove lower balance for
so the correlation polytope which plays
a really key role in all of this
literature is the very simple polytope
in n squared dimensions
all you do is you take every binary
string a of length n
you take a times a transpose so this is
a rank one binary matrix and you take
the convex hull of all such matrices
that's your polytope
now the important thing is that actually
a sub matrix of the slack matrix in the
natural way
the vertices are identified with binary
strings it turns out that you can also
generate a valid constraint on the
correlation poly through a binary string
and moreover that the entry how slack
that constraint is on
you know some particular vertex turns
out to be this really nice expression 1
minus a transpose b squared now why is
this nice it's nice because we can think
about alice as having the string a and
bob is having the string b
in which case whether or not this entry
is zero or non-zero
is just a disjointness problem
if a and b are disjoint then s is
certainly non-zero because i get one
minus zero squared but if they uniquely
intersect in just one location then i
get a transpose b is one and i get one
minus one square to zero so in fact
they're really computing some sort of
unique disjointness problem
so i'll very quickly tell you why this
actually arises a very short proof why
this arises as you know the slack matrix
is it's just the manipulation on
inequality so i take what i want the
slack to be
and i want to figure out a constraint
that realizes that slack on some vertex
so i just expand what this inequality is
but i use the fact that a is binary that
a and b are binary to actually rewrite
this term inside so the interpretation a
and b is the same thing as the inner
product between a diagonal matrix b
along the diagonal and the matrix a
times a transpose
and i can rearrange the inequalities the
left-hand side is non-negative
so in fact this inequality is valid one
is certainly at least this quantity
where this is my vertex and this is some
direction
so this is a valid inequality and
moreover the slack is exactly 1 minus a
transpose b squared
so this is exactly how you get
you know disjointness as a sub matrix in
the slack problem but now to realize
this program that i described what you
need to do is you need to choose a set
of the entries in the matrix which all
have the same value i'm going to do it
in the natural way that you prove lower
balance for disjointness and information
complexity
i'm going to choose it over all pairs a
and b which are disjoint
so that set actually has three to the
end possibilities because you know for a
i comma b i have three possibilities 0 0
0 1 or 1 0. and what i'm going to do now
is that really is something which all
the entries are the same in the slack
matrix they're all one in the way i've
defined it
and if i think about the sampling
procedure what it's really doing is it's
saying let me give you a different way
to sample from t using the the
non-negative matrix factorization
this non-negative matrix factorization
is really a way to break up the
distribution into different pieces
and instead of choosing a random entry
from t i'm going to look at each of
these rank 1 terms how much it
contributes to t
i'm going to choose one of them
proportional their total value
and then once i've chosen which rank 1
matrix i'm going to output an actual
pair in t proportional to its relative
value
so that's just restating what the
sampling procedure is
and now all we have to do is we have to
account for this entropy and show that
there's an information theoretic
contradiction
so the key point is that we know how
many bits of randomness there are in a
uniformly random sample from t
there's three to the n choices for t so
we just have n times log two base of
three it's very simple
now there are only two steps in this
sampling procedure it's also very simple
you know i have to choose this i this is
which of the rank 1 matrices i'm going
to sample from because i've broken up
the distribution
and this is at most log r because
they're only r of these matrices so
worst case it's the uniform distribution
on them
and what i claim is at the end of the
day all i have to do is show that i've
saved something on the entropy that when
i get to this last step and i've
restricted to a rank one matrix then
instead of the naive bound of you know n
log three bits of entropy as soon as i
save any constant factor and i get a 1
minus delta there this will actually
imply an exponential lower bound for r
that's the point
so let's do it
so let me give you a simplified version
of the argument you know let's say that
we've already chosen which of these rank
1 matrices we're sampling from so mi is
fixed
and let's say i've fixed all of the
entries in a except for aj and all of
the entries in b except for bj and i'm
really just concerned about how do i
choose these two see the naive bound for
this is that i would think i have three
possibilities zero zero zero one and one
zero that would be bad because then i'm
really not gaining anything and the
question is why have i gained something
so remember we're sampling from mi just
restricted to all the choices we made so
far
so let me just you know that's a sub
matrix of the original matrix where i
plug in you know all the three different
possibilities zero zero zero one and one
zero let me also plug in one one even
though i would never consider that just
for simplicity this is a sub matrix and
the key point in all of this this is the
punch line
is that in this entry
if we really did fill in aj equals one
and bj equals one we would have a pair
of strings that uniquely intersects
and then the answer to unique
disjointness would be zero so that means
that this matrix has to have a zero
there because that's what the entry
should be in the slack matrix and once
you put in something non-negative you
can never cancel it out again
but now i'm done because i have a zero
in a rank one matrix which means there
has to be another zero somewhere in
either the same row or same column
wherever it is you thought that you had
three possibilities of zero zero zero
one and one zero but you actually only
have two possibilities so the
conditional entropy in your sampling of
actually aj bj is only one bit not log
three
so there's a way to get this to work in
a sort of amortized way because i can't
really fix all of a except for aj and
all of b except for bj it's a very
standard trick in information complexity
with how exactly to use the chain rule
for mutual information
but you get that same bound for actually
the entire thing that instead of n times
log three bits of entropy you only need
n
and that implies the exponential lower
bound
for the correlation polytope through
this information theoretic argument so
the point does a too good to be true
non-negative matrix factorization would
allow you to sample from some very
simple distribution using too few bits
of entropy
in fact to answer thomas's question you
can actually use this much further to
proving lower bounds on even getting the
polytope somewhat right
so it turns out for example if you want
to know
now that the slack now that the
correlation polytope can't be
represented very well with fewer than
exponential constraints
what if instead you want to fit a
polytope between
the correlation polytope and some
scaling up of the correlation polytope
so as c gets larger and larger this
becomes easier and easier to fit a
polytube between them but actually has a
very simple effect on the slack matrix
all you do is you add c
so instead of it being the unique
disjointness problem where a and b are
disjoint you have to output one and if
they're uniquely intersecting you have
to output zero you're instead outputting
either c plus one or c
so it's kind of like not trying to solve
unique disjointness exactly but get some
advantage over random guessing
like trying to get a you know half plus
one over c type of you know guarantee
for the probability computed correctly
so it turns out that actually
through you can make this connection
even stronger that proving lower bounds
against even barely beating random
guessing for communication tasks can
actually show you that you can't get you
know geometric problems like the
correlation polytope even approximately
right within non-trivial factors
so it turns out there's actually a
natural barrier for a lot of the
techniques that we have for proving
lower bounds for communication
complexity at c is roughly root n so
that type of advantage
so you know i'm sure many of you know
for example that there are linear lower
bounds for getting disjointness right
with constant probability so getting it
right with three-quarters probability
now the point is that that can actually
black box be used as a way to prove a
lower bound on barely beating random
guessing that if your goal is to beat
random guessing by a one over c factor
you can actually prove that you need at
least n over c squared bits
all you would do is you would just take
a protocol that solves this using little
o of n over c squared bits you'd run it
c squared times take the majority vote
and then that would violate your
original linear lower bound for
disjointness
well it turns out that you can actually
prove a stronger lower bound that it's
not just n over c as the lower bound
for getting advantage one over c uh n
over c squared you can actually prove an
n over c lower bound that's exactly the
type of argument the potential function
that's used in here is exactly what gets
you to this extended formulation all the
way up to size n to the one minus
epsilon so the correlation polytope you
know the same way the clique is hard to
approximate within n to the one minus
epsilon so too this correlation polytube
has exactly the same type of property
that it's hard to get right even all the
way up to n to the one minus epsilon at
which point it's trivial
so i think i'll stop there but the quick
summary was
i gave you an introduction to extended
formulations this geometric property of
giving polytopes new names
it has a lot of cases where you really
can that's based on some cool
combinatorial ideas
uh and there are a lot of cases where
you really believe you can't and you can
prove
unconditional lower bounds through this
program yanakakis introduced
based on relationship between the
geometry and the algebra
but in turn you can actually think about
lower bounding these purely
representational questions about lps
through information theory and that's a
very smooth measure that ends up being
very useful
even improving lower bounds on
approximately getting things like the
correlation polytope right so i'll end
there but thanks
is there a chance we could extend the
sampling argument to a lower bound psd
ring
so that's a good question uh so i wonder
if you can use like some sort of quantum
uh information theory
uh quantum information theory seems not
so easy to work with like i still can't
wrap my head around the fact that
conditional entropy is not non-negative
and that mutual information proving it's
non-negative is quite non-trivial
but
i mean for other reasons i've been
looking at some of these quantum
definitions and i think
there's a lot of issues there about
which norms are used in uh quantum
information theory and some of them are
not
you know as strong as one would like
with like the one-way loc and stuff but
that's a good question
thanks all right thanks
you